see how y'all doing Kelly yeah how are
you doing oh my gosh hello to both of
you how are you good
I am such a big fan of both of you so
I'm so happy you're both doing my show I
think you're both hysterical so this
podcast is somewhat you know kind of
bring you back to your Ridge because you
were both on radio together right yes we
did because I'm doing the morning show
together
I'm join a morning show together for
almost four years and we had such a
chemistry and all that time I said can
we should just do a podcast because we
love to talk like we talked three times
a day and I said it'd just be so fun to
just talk about stuff that we know about
you know raising kids our relationships
or lack thereof and everything so we
started this podcast we financed
ourselves know we do microphones lights
made us she kept she kept she kept
saying we need to do a podcast together
we need to do a podcast together and I
just I was dragging my feet but now I
love it
that's cuz you get to sit home in your
pajamas
well that is true I know I would look I
don't like zooming like this like
innocence that you miss the energy of
like the show or even as a singer like
being on stage but I do love the fact
that I'm wearing flip-flops with this
cute little number the dress is not like
and you can't see the bottom half of me
that's the best part of this job right
now I'm choked up and I forgot I had on
shorts like I have a pretty I do have
insurance right now my pajama bottoms oh
my god you done I love it hey why not
they can't see it well until you pop up
so you got the idea for the podcast
though from when you would try to one-up
each other
with celebrity name drops right yeah
because we were talking because we
started to funny mamas podcast just to
talk but when we were we were talking we
realized we knew a lot of celebrities
like for me I knew trends because I got
to get on stage at Madison Square Garden
and dance with Prince what Oh see that
is near a prince invited me to his house
and I was neither Baker concert in a
meter brought me on stage to sing the
whole last half of her song so excuse me
but do you know this found you give good
love to me
uh-huh Anita Baker right there no no
Megan the stallion I was in the studio
and when she was riding I'm a savage it
started off is I'm a sandwich and I told
her that I'm sound like I'm a saint and
it was supposed to I'm a sandwich yes
yes helped Jermaine Jackson you remember
the song Kelly Clarkson Kelly goes not
cool enough to work with on American
Idol when Kelly was on there and I was
like girl go deeper
I'm back with the two buddy mamas Sherri
Shepherd and Kym Whitley and that was a
clip from sharri's Netflix series mr.
glaze yes you can watch those episodes
streaming right now but Sherri okay you
play a principal in this show and I
understand you now have some experience
as a real-life educator well you know
Kim and I we both are teachers to our
sons we're both like home school
teachers I keep you know I want to bow
down to every educator and then I really
didn't know my son was like this happen
I don't know what Josh but does Kim but
he'll be having a history lesson lady
it's so annoying like and I'm like just
do it and it'll be done
Joshua all the time don't you just do it
just do it
no no charity already knows I
I had to go to the doctor because the
whole school has stressed me out I have
heart palpitations I couldn't get the
work in I don't know how to scam it in
the teachers like where's the work and
too much me heart palpitations is in Y
squared equals PI I said PI I know
because I eat back so a lot of people
are trying to take this time to get in
shape I am NOT one of them but there are
people I hear of so Kim and Sheree how
have you guys been staying healthy and
Quarantine well I am happy to say for me
I was lucky that I am the new ambassador
for WW which is formerly Weight Watchers
thank you Carrie
yes I'm very excited about they came
with the perfect time because watching
TV eating cooking and teaching and
everything to de-stress it up but now
that I'm on WWI am now 18 pounds down
Wow numbers like counting you're good
with all that yeah I didn't think I
could do it cuz I've never done it
before yeah but that watches I mean ww
yeah we don't his Weight Watchers
yeah cuz really I'm totally saved you
Kelly really saved me anything else is
on my body I gained it all yeah well
Sherry's upper body is very strong
I started all my girlfriends where we
were doing we were getting to 50 pushups
in 30 days and this is so everybody had
to send in a video of their push-ups and
we almost got to 50 Kim sent me the
video recently she did three and then I
couldn't post to Kelly because she
didn't have her hair oh good lord
okay well I understand Kim you're dating
as well how are you dating during this
time oh honey it is the best thing I
mean what I mean
this Kovach thing is course the curse
but a blessing at the same time because
what I have found out is that since we
have this you can date men you don't
have to sleep with him you get to know
them they don't have to see what you
have
on the bottom because you meet them in
your car six feet away they don't know
that you haven't washed in days it is
saying million they can smell you and
you get to know each other so it's been
good for me because I go on these these
social distancing dates that either
where the park or far away or were you
know in a car so we don't have to touch
each other and then I could make a
decision if I like you or not I just
don't - Molly woods because then you
find out if you actually really like
them thank you yeah I got these lips for
a reason buddy
can you imagine the tension like the
build-up that's gonna be amazing like
when you can't touch each other you
can't see each other and you're talking
about and you're like just whew it's
gonna be good
and then it happens I'm gonna make over
that no I want you to tap I want your
Cova test tattooed on your like on your
connected wrinkles and I just want
that's what I want I want to kiss your
negative kovat Sheri has Kelly Sheri has
a mask with a flap okay
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going